what's up man how you doing brother
oh good man just wanted to wish you
congratulations the game you gotta catch
the grant cardone
listen four years ago I had 7000
subscribers four years ago and it was
three videos a day most people aren't
putting up enough content uh-huh how
much you putting up you putting up one
daily oh no you're doing six a day on
YouTube I have 6,000 videos so so we're
but equal then you know what that is
just paying attention you need a man you
need you need a good date ahead you need
a nerd yeah you mean a data geek to go
through and tell you what series are
taking off and which ones are yeah okay
what's the third thing you know what
whoever manages your thing let me talk
to them
I'll pour through your data also in half
an hour with them and well like we'll
fix it oh you deserve to be you deserve
to be two million on YouTube man good
put me in touch with all your all your
YouTube back and stuff we'll fix it
we'll fix it right that's why you guys
want to collaborate man y'all need to
collaborate with people you connect and
that's what Evan Carmichael doesn't
really good job of collaborating with
other people interviewing them
showcasing them he's done I don't know
five or six different videos of of how I
run my life in my business and he's
taking interest in what I'm doing and
that's that's that give give give
philosophy that I talk about all the
time also if you want to know what I
think and what others
successful entrepreneurs think about
building confidence check out my new to
54 confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days for free I will send
you a 30 second a five minute video in
the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below if you want to be
more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you loved you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want more grant cardone check out
the day in the life of Grant Cardone
video that my team shot the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there hey you guys use your body
man you don't have to be a bodybuilder
like this beast over here use your body
use it or lose it